good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast the morning zoom we
are here virtually live with you in
spirit and in audio and video hey Claude
hey guys hope everyone's doing well
happy Thursday happy the last day of
Passover I went on Amazon spree
yesterday in anticipation of all the
delicious snacks that have leavened
bread that I'm going to eat today first
up cookie dough do I have an oven no but
I have a toaster oven and I read them on
in the internet that you can make um
cookies in the toaster oven and then I
also got pizza bagels and then I got
tacos I'm just like having a fiesta
tonight amigas cheetahs friends for life
oh my god that sounds so so fabulous I'm
so excited for Passover to break I have
a home chef meal that I was about to
make the night before Passover started
um but then I forgot to make it and it
was Passover it's like a deconstructed
lasagna you were making fun of me for it
look and I hope the ingredients are
still I hope the ingredients are still
fresh because I'm gonna be making that
tonight and I'm also recording a patreon
day in the life of Quarantine with me um
so you guys will get to see whatever I
decide to break make that Passover
faster on the whole point of a lasagna
is to be constructed so this like the
the sense of a deconstructed lasagna
makes no sense today I mean here you are
just like yakking my yums and I'm
excited about it and you just can't be
excited for me and that hurts no I'm
excited for you
I just I can't get behind who's ever
like like whatever sommelier like chef
that hello fresh hired to like come up
with these like brand new like young
fresh ingredients like I just can't get
behind his idea like thinking that
deconstructed lasagna was like a smart
choice you know what it is actually they
try and make dishes that you can make
with like they expect that you don't
have every single pan and casserole dish
in your thing and lasagna you need that
dish that I don't have you guys recall
where it's like a clear cast it's a
casserole dish I don't have that so they
gave me a lasagna I wouldn't be able to
make it they made it so that I can make
it in my pants which is a very
thoughtful because it's for the amateur
chef Jackie that's beautiful
Thank You Claudia I put
hard into it okay anyone ever gets to
see my comedy special he will understand
all these references you know what's so
funny as I was reading I was up all
night this quarantine like I cannot
[ __ ] sleep it's reading no oh sorry I
was reading Facebook posts in the group
and in tipsy toasters someone commented
like a day ago and like it literally
there was one comment but she was like
does anyone else feel like Claudia Jack
you've changed and like in the past few
days some girl was like what do you mean
she's like I just feel like there's a
level to the show that like I don't
understand anymore like so many inside
jokes and I feel like a lot of that has
to do with us quoting my comedy special
because nobody's seen it but like we
know that's beautiful
so and I've actually been getting a lot
of questions like about Seanie lexicon
and I think maybe it might behoove us to
do like a podcast segment where we take
questions like explaining what people
aren't understanding okay I could do
that maybe we'll do that and no tomorrow
we have like so much to recap maybe
we'll do that on like a Tuesday you know
Monday Wednesday Wednesday steer
toasters and yesterday steer toaster
guide had me cryin I literally was up in
bed putting it on my TV making Ben watch
the Carlos Santana thing oh my god it's
so funny it's so funny um I feel that
well I'm glad that that's how we change
just because we're getting even more
like into our own inside jokes and not
just like you know the fame has gone to
our heads like all this I mean I would
love to say that to well literally I was
up all night just like reading stuff
about myself that's what I do when I
can't sleep in there like Heidi and then
like I can't sleep anymore I almost got
to a point almost where I was on reddit
okay oh my god why were you doing that I
just couldn't sleep and like there was
like there was such Jews dry on the
internet like there was nothing for me
to really look at on Instagram and Ben
was asleep so I couldn't watch tic TOCs
and then I was just like searching like
Twitter and stuff and then I was like
maybe if I just pressed this I was just
looking for something stimulating and I
wasn't finding it and like talk to you
like hearing what people have to say
about me um it's often quite stimulating
interesting well did anyone say anything
about me no I I didn't go there
oh okay cool but I actually since I like
wet down that rabbit hole and it's
really hard for me like to come out of
it so I really purposely they try not to
let myself go to places like that um and
I almost likes how to slip up but I
didn't I'm good oh my god that's so dark
I was so stimulated last night because
we recorded our episode of the redheads
it was so good it's like an hour and 30
minutes almost of us just like talking
about this book that we all loved but I
put together our four audio files so it
really the audio is like such premium
quality it was really a labor of love I
recorded the episode at five o'clock and
I finished editing it at 11:30 so I was
literally working on it for like six
hours straight so please listen to it
for those who are wondering why Jackie
and I are back to zoom we have made the
very difficult but necessary decision to
temporarily stop filming
it just is what's best for everyone and
while we are sad because we know a lot
of people like live for the live stream
and really have come to rely on it in
these quarantine times we just have to
do what's best for our company for us
and that's doing zoom so we will let you
know when we're back in studio but it
won't be for a little bit yeah zooms not
that bad I feel like the episode on
Monday people enjoyed um will get better
with our audio hopefully I mean now that
I'm using a microphone that should be
good and if it's not good enough we'll
try something else so this is not good
enough I did a podcast with Taylor's
trekker I don't know if it came out yet
but it was literally like sensational
audio but that's also because you were
in our studio and you had our which he
wasn't so like we could be using our
podcast equipment the key is to record
your podcast if anyone's like a podcasts
are looking for how to make quality
content in this quarantine times its to
FaceTime with the person that you're
podcasting with both you have to wear
headphones and then you have to use your
own podcast equipment to record on a
totally separate device so like a zoom
or your computer and and it's okay so if
this doesn't work out I have good ideas
for tomorrow and next week but I think
this should be a well then it would be a
good podcast but how would we get a
video for youtube oh we wouldn't or we
could record the screen the FaceTime but
I don't know I don't know about that
okay so we're gonna try and make this
work without further ado but is it very
slow news day but we did not want to
leave you without a show so let's just
get right into the fast
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
okay Klee I'm feeling very vulnerable
like having my bedroom on display do you
know what I mean like I I had to make my
bed and stuff mm-hmm no I moved to the
bedroom as well because I was filming in
our quote-unquote Home Office and the
lighting was just not good I have so
much white noise coming from my AC unit
which I've never even turned on in my
life and it's just always roaring yeah
you got to turn it off that's the life
of a podcaster you always start sweating
when you broadcast I don't turn it off
I've never turned it on it just makes
noise it sits there and like hums so I
came to the bedroom so I can be in front
of my vanity yeah it does it does
I don't use it I even pellet on in that
room and I don't turn the AC on because
I wanted to feel like soul cycles so
like oh my god you're sitting I've never
Li never turned the air conditioning on
in that room yet the machine is finding
a way to be heard that's good I think my
lighting is better in here I'm further
away from Zack so I'm not like you know
embarrassing him on his work calls
talking about Santana it does it I don't
know my bedroom is just like not it I
think I need to move okay let's get into
the first story because Michael che is
paying rent for the New York City
neighbors of his grandmother who died of
current iris this is such a sweet story
Michael che is paying homage to his
grandmother Martha who recently died of
coronavirus complications in the kindest
way possible the SNL star will pay one
month's rent for 160 residents in his
grandmother's public housing complex in
New York City quote it's crazy to me
that residents of public housing are
still expected to pay their rent when so
many New Yorkers can't even work he
wrote on Instagram obviously I can't
offer much help by myself but in the
spirit and memory of my late grandmother
I'm paying one month's rent for all 160
apartments in the NY CH a building she
lived in that's so sweet but really
shedding light on a much larger issue
that public housing residents should not
have to pay rent during the quarantine
and to be honest like you know I'm not
one for politics and I think that
Governor Cuomo is doing such a fabulous
job really taking New York you know and
making it into a livable place again but
this is falling on the hands of bill de
blasio the mayor because this is a
mayoral thing and is a New York City
thing right it's not a New York State
thing like Governor Cuomo's in Albany
like for the state like there are things
outside Manhattan and Bill de Blasio is
suppose to be in charge of Manhattan and
he has been totally useless
and trying to help with Governor Cuomo
and like just trying to like alleviate
New York City as one of the biggest hubs
in the world of coronavirus um and to me
this is just like such an easy thing
that should be taken care of and here
yet again being disappointed by de
Blasio I cannot wait for him to be out
of office I'll literally take no eights
it's so crazy like he doesn't even have
to do anything or come up with any ideas
on his own during the pandemic just like
listen to the people follow Governor
Cuomo and just like follow what people
are doing that people like you know yeah
and you know what if I was a politician
I would actually use this um quarantine
and and whole pandemic to my advantage
because people are really really
struggling like they're looking for the
first time ever like I've literally
never thought in my life like I need to
turn to my governor or I need to turn to
my mayor but people are really turning
to like their leaders and Bill de Blasio
it's like a disgrace towards politics
he's a disgrace towards leaders
everywhere like those shoes were meant
for a beautiful woman and if that's the
case like he shouldn't have had them he
shouldn't be wearing them because he is
nothing of the sort
it's so [ __ ] crazy this city is in
shambles I can't believe like we're the
greatest city in the world and I just I
can't even get into it it's it's people
who say New York is the greatest city in
the world haven't been here never been
here's nobody used to be like fabulous
like when you watch breakfast at
tiffany's yeah fabulous it's not that
anymore
it's row you were an ex chick I think in
the last ten it goes in and out I feel
like New York is always like up and down
just like anything else it's a Ramona
coaster but I feel like in the last ten
years it's really gone to [ __ ] like even
when it was like Gossip Girl when we
were in high school like things were
poppin you know maybe just because we
were we like it was a nice place to be
and there were so many restaurants and
it was clean like you can tell where New
York is at in terms of like leadership
and just based on the cleanliness of
course just take a walk down a street
like you'll know what's good okay this
next story is so crazy I didn't see
anyone writing about it except for of
course pop crave news but
- ANOVA is trending on Twitter after the
retail company sent a mass text to their
customers promoting the spending of
stimulus checks on their products so
they sent a push notification to people
who opted in for fashion / pushing
notifications that said when the
stimulus deposit hits save up to 80% off
site-wide use code stay in 80 okay like
no no not this is not what the
government intended no but I do have to
say three things
why this is incredibly out of touch and
like borderline insensitive to people
who are like waiting on this check to
like pay their rent put food on the
table like it's just so out of touch I
can't even but it is my understanding
that the whole concept of stimulus
checks is to stimulate the economy and
like a yes assist in businesses and
therefore faster Nova would be
considered a business like I get it
but the third thing is I just want to
know like how many people had to like
approve this afraid to go through like
fashion it was actually a pretty big
company like they they're fast fashion
they make a lot of money like they
definitely hire a lot of people I would
just love to know like how many people
thought this was a good idea you know
what I don't even think it's sad I think
that whoever does their social and
whoever does their push notifications
does a really good job I think that
person has pretty much absolute power
when it comes to what goes out I think
that that person spends a lot of time on
the internet on tick tock and got like
just assume this was a good idea because
this is the zeitgeist but it just really
misses the mark in terms of people who
need that money not to spend it on like
fast fashion that employs slave laborers
um and instead to put food on their
table and take care of their families
yeah like they should be putting food on
the table not buying a spandex dress
that literally will rip the second you
put it around once I yeah it's just it's
not it it's like it's honestly a really
funny [ __ ] up yeah but yeah I mean
they're they but fashion of it is so
controversial in general like the I
don't even think this even scratches the
surface of what's wrong with them as a
company you get that that article that
they literally pay their workers like $2
an hour like below minimum wage it's
like no lead laborer mm-hmm America are
like in a sweatshop in Calif in
California
whoo not gonna make a pepper abroad but
it's just a lot of companies I watched
in in one of my classes in college you
made us watch this documentary about how
they took like five European like young
bloggers who were like really spoiled
and took them to a sweatshop in Cambodia
that makes clothing for Zahra hmm and
they made them work in a sweatshop for
one day and these kids were like dying
from the circumstances it was a total
expose on the whole fast fashion
industry that's crazy
yeah affect fashion over I agree like
they're used to controversy honestly
that's probably busted sales for them so
whatever works yeah well I don't think
this will affect them at all it's
honestly just kind of funny um but
whatever okay another brand with a faux
pas that's making it ready is Reese
Witherspoon who's donating to teach her
aid organization after a Draper
James flaps oh I didn't hear about this
but it turns out Draper James this week
caught flak for a giveaway that
backfired went into underestimated
demand I guess it was a giveaway for a
free dress for teachers a million
teachers entered the contest for a free
dress and the company was only offering
250 so I guess they caught some backlash
I mean how could they get a million
that's crazy I had no idea that this
brain was so popular was the premise of
the giveaway to give one away to
everyone who entered or just like a
contest I think just a contest but um so
what's the problem
and how does everyone know how many
people entered
that's how giveaways people enter one up
wins education professionals were
directed to an online application form
with a deadline and told that winners
would be notified the following week and
sent their dresses while supplies last
the wild Draper James initial
announcement was well intentioned and
met with much fanfare they seem to
underestimate how many teachers would
take them up on the offer there are more
than three million public school
teachers in the US alone
so maybe it was like if you if you
entered teachers who assumed they were
entering a giveaway rather than a raffle
are sharing their frustration on social
media so I said great a giveaway is
different than a raffle though because
it's not just like oh a few it's like
we're giving it away I don't know she
won zero to fifty is a giveaway I'm
sorry in my opinion there's nothing
wrong with this contest that's how
contests and giveaways and sweepstakes
work it wouldn't be exciting if everyone
won of course I will anyways get a dress
but that's not how the company that's
not how the giveaway works why are you
apologizing this makes no sense if I
must be this well she's Reese
Witherspoon made a donation to the
nonprofit donors choose to support three
southern city support teachers and three
southern cities the donation from Reese
and her fashion line Draper James will
support all of our highest need teachers
in New Orleans Atlanta and Nashville and
many more throughout the country that's
fabulous I love a donation I just need
to know what controversy was really
there that spiral just donate for no
reason you got through a controversy and
you donate that's how being a celebrity
works I feel like there's something
about I'll read the article again I feel
like there's something we are missing as
to why this is so if they're guilty of
something every brand including the
toast is guilty of doing a giveaway
giveaways are meant to be where winners
are selected I'm not understanding and
if this is like the the level of
heightened cancel culture we've got to
and then I'm shook okay this is what the
the angry teachers were tweeting out of
535 teachers on a social media page on
Facebook not even one got a free drape
or James dress what in the what they all
received codes for either twenty to
thirty percent off discount codes they
said can't even afford the dresses with
a disc round great Margaret great
marketing ploy another one Wow Trevor
James
doesn't know how much teachers make we
love teachers here's 30% of our
ridiculously expensive dresses if I'm
spending $100 on an everyday dress it
better also grade essays okay I'm still
not understand so the teacher said but
you gotta protect the seizures you have
to protect the teachers but so are they
mad that they didn't win the contest or
that they never were able to win the
contest
there's a difference but if you didn't
win that's how it works
I'm very good I'm frustrating to them to
have not won but like just because just
and during this specific contest
guarantee willing it I don't know I
don't know and just because this one
Facebook group got mad Reese Witherspoon
had to make a donation it sounds like a
like a subgroup of people who hate the
toast no totally I have no idea that's a
really crazy story so yeah well you know
what at the end of the day more money to
charity the teachers are benefiting and
we'd love to benefit the teachers a
thousand percent taking the load off of
them so whatever weird turn of events
kyle reese witherspoon to make a sizable
donation to donors choice like here for
it I love exploiting celebrity like
controversy just makes money for charity
the charity world man
it's just crazy it is really crazy our
fourth and final story is that Kanye
West is on the cover of GQ oh my god so
I haven't read the article yet and I
want to read it because I hate when
people like try and sum up what Kanye
said it's like that's not what he had
said you know but so I read Kanye West
is on the cover of GQ and in tank and I
was like oh like he's my tank top like
who cares and then I was like I saw the
cover I'm like that's on tank top I was
like but it's a chain literally like a
tiny tank he loves a tank moment yeah I
didn't read the article either I'm just
like happy for him and whatever like
he's spewing sometimes I just can't
literally can't keep up with the
Kardashians like there's too much I know
but it's just like he's sharing his in
the article it's called inside Kanye
West's vision for the future
first he changed the sound of popular
music then he
revolutionised fashion and sneakers now
kanye west's redesigning the very
building blocks of family life food
clothing and shelter and he's claimed
thousands of acres in wyoming as a test
site for his ideas GQ followed Kanye
from Cody to Calabasas from Cabo San
Lucas to Paris to see it all firsthand
and to talk to him about his next album
his altered ego oh that's interesting as
opposed to alter ego altered ego because
he changed his ego and his renewed faith
in God bouncy bouncy like yeah honestly
must fit must have been super fun for
whatever like intern journalist got to
travel with Kanye from Cabo San Lucas to
Paris you know like do you think that
they put him on the plane and I made him
fly commercial I think they put it on
the plane they're pretty good about
putting people on the plane unless
Kourtney's coming and then the trainers
and the security have to fly commercial
tonight oh yes I was Real Housewives of
New York I'm hoping we're gonna get
better episodes of both because this
past week just didn't do it for me in
terms of New York housewives or Keeping
Up with the Kardashians I have a high
bar especially after watching this
stellar sensational inspired and
fabulous premiere of Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills like that's my level now
and I don't feel like I should watch
anything less than that yes so I feel
like that's a great segue to recap Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills which is
really like the reason for the season
the reason we did an episode today
because it was oozing fabulosity I just
I've never been so excited every time
Beverly Hills comes back like I get
chills like I'm excited but this in my
opinion was one of the best season
premieres of any franchise ever okay
here's the thing I like kind of agree
with you me but um I feel like it was
just the best because we were so excited
but when you break it down to its
essential bit and because we love all
the women like it all revolved around
this Kyle Richards New York Fashion Week
fashion show that was like so season one
I feel like anytime a housewife does a
fashion show it's like so janky and so
like season 1 season 2 housewives and I
just couldn't believe that season 10 of
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills like
Kyle is taking us back there with some
janky ass fashion show where her
daughters and her cast mates are walking
okay yes I agree like we are so above
just in Beverly Hills and the fact that
we're on season 10 like we're above a
fashion show put together with
scotch tape I totally agree but in
Kyle's defense like it was as good as it
could have been like she did get Pier 59
at New York Fashion Week she had a full
production like Kyle at Paris and Nikki
were there like it was the highest level
housewives fashion show by a mile and I
didn't think it was so janky yes I'm
like over a fashion show in a housewives
like franchise because it's so silly
like it's never been real but it was it
was at the level that I expected it to
be huh I don't know it was just and even
seeing the behind the scenes and it's
like she hasn't even seen the garments
it was like what is going on guys Kyle
Richards like putting her name on this
why she always doing these
collaborations like there's something
that I'm not understanding and she was
like talking with three like I'm not
just gonna put my name on something like
that I don't believe in and it's like
why are you even in this position like
you just have a clothing store I just I
didn't understand I actually I did I do
agree that the fashion show came out as
best as it possibly could um but there
was something so season one of it I
can't explain I didn't until you
mentioned it like I didn't really get
like all bent out of shape over it like
you're right like it is it is below them
for sure but like it didn't impact the
way that I felt or like the episode
because to me there was so much to the
episode including the fashion show but I
just I don't even know where to start
let's start with our two new ladies
because just absolutely like even saying
the words fashion show like I feel so
corny like I'm I can't and you know it's
the only person I'll take a fashion show
from now from now on on the Real
Housewives honestly like the only one
who makes me feel something with their
fashion show who dream Melissa Gorga no
Melissa Gorga I love her fashion show
it's like family she is who she is she's
like running down the runway like being
herself she actually owns a clothing
store like I like her version of a
fashion show but when anyone else is
like what bring it to New York Fashion
Week like oh my god maybe I just don't
go to enough fashion make stuff and
that's actually how it's done but just I
can't with a fashion show okay I really
didn't think it was that if they don't
me feel like it makes me feel like when
we were like eight years old and used to
walk down our hallway Emden like fashion
show that's what Melissa Gorga's was
like Kyle's had a production like
there was a lot of press there I was
actually invited and couldn't make it
and like was lamenting the whole episode
that I wasn't there um and why can't you
make it I've had someone in there like I
was I was I had another commitment what
could have been like more popping than
that
honestly I remember like being upset
that I wasn't able to know because I
knew they were filming damn that sucks
um okay let's talk about the two new
women because Garcelle Bouvier was just
like everything like I shoot very
seamlessly like even though it was
obvious she didn't really know anyone
except for Denise
everyone was super welcoming um I just I
had such a good feeling about her like
she's funny she didn't like sometimes
when somebody joins and I think this
happened a little bit with Teddy
Mellencamp like they're just so eager to
like be a part of the group that they're
very much like a people pleaser they
don't really add much to conversation
until they get comfortable book our cell
is very much like a force and I think a
lot of the women like respected her vibe
especially Erika Jayne and I could see a
very powerful friendship between the two
I totally agree I loved her energy I
love that she like didn't pretend like
she didn't know who these people are but
she's still getting to know them she's
not just like making assumptions about
them they some what they wear like some
other people Sutton is like the whoa
Dias won't I've ever voted you know what
I have to have to say I thoroughly
disliked Sutton but not for the reasons
that one might think like I just I I'm
100% sure that like production was
asking her questions like what do you
think of Teddy's outfit like I don't
think she's generally like that like
just going around and being mean about
people's outfits I'm sure what she said
was her truth but I just think she was
provoked saying that what I really
disliked about her was that like I don't
know if she's as rich as everyone says
she is like that's just not how rich
people act like even when when she got
to go to Dolce & Gabbana's house and get
dressed by them like and it was
obviously like a very prestigious thing
that happens to her a lot she was just
being so braggy about it like and so
ostentatious like not not gracious and
not like I just I just felt like if that
was something that happens for her
regularly like and she was a really
really rich person people like that
would act differently like they would
act with more grace she was just being
so show off II and so braggy like to
Lisa Rinna and for the cameras like it
was just giving me like a really bad bye
but she's
the worst type of rich person
interesting yeah I'm gonna reserve
actual like judgment of her until we get
to know her a little better because
right now we're only like we haven't
really had oh no we did have a
confessional with her but I want to see
her home life and like I want to get to
know her maybe there's more to her like
but this was just not a good debut
episode considering like our cell was
there and just like showed you how it's
done um it was just a little clunky
and you know what maybe like this
explains why she doesn't have a diamond
maybe she's not getting one because it
seems like with all the drama about to
take off like if she doesn't ingratiate
herself in the group quickly she's got
to get left behind because like we're
turning to the knees soon yeah also I
was getting the vibe that she like new
to housewives formula and was just like
saying and doing things because she
wants to be a housewife which is the
worst type of mentality you can come in
with and I do think that like she starts
petty fights and like is a little nuts
and it comes off inauthentic and I think
that she might end up not being a
housewife just because she's not good at
it
yeah and the other women like she might
have been able to be a housewife in
another city but the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills are just on another level
like my girl to read like was she extra
precious this episode or was it just me
um she was a little [ __ ] about the
fashion show like she literally went to
one meeting and claimed that the show
wouldn't have gone on without her know
she was a little [ __ ] and her
confessional but not at the UM not in
real-time which makes me feel like
something might happen between her and
Kyle to like make her talk like so
negatively also Kyle was like tweeting
shady like she was live tweeting the
episode is just like being Shady
especially about the things that you
read said like taking credit for all of
Kyle and like the production Tracy's
team's work I know but we I know but the
fact that Kyle was like beefing with her
production team it was just very season
one and you know what I was that was
funny was very it was very Real
Housewives of Orange County when they
had a fashion show on the boat I happen
to think that was hilarious when she got
a phone call and they were like Tracy
said she wants to stay away from you
today I thought that was hilarious
because that woman Tracy was like being
so angry at the meeting at Chiquita's
before I didn't have like that reaction
to the fashion show that you did but I
totally understand in respect why you
yeah but I will say ultimately I really
liked a lot of the clothes I completely
agree with Garcelle that Erika was in
the wrong outfit I loved when to eat
when to the showroom or whatever the
closet um when she put on that uh look
at RIT she's got like trench but it kind
of looks like like like your pajamas
vibe um I absolutely loved it totally do
like a lot of the clothes I'm excited to
see where this goes for Kyle because
that really is her signature style I
just wish there was a way to showcase
your new fashion line without having a
fashion show yeah I I agree I thought
the fashion line was actually pretty
cute while not everything was for me I
could see Kyle Richards wearing
everything and so for her to put her
face her name to that I understood why
she was like Alpha Klimt when like
shahida was out making ugly yellow
mustard tops yeah yeah I agree and also
satin like respected the the clothes as
well and so did Carson and I I feel like
it actually was good stuff I wonder well
they wonder where you got it I feel like
you would actually look like really good
in a lot of that stuff thank you all so
really quickly I did a little research
on sudden Strax husband because Lisa was
like he's a hedge fund money money money
baseball teams and I found his like net
worth being a six hundred and ninety
thousand dollars so no it's obviously
not real but like just makes you think I
thought you were gonna say six hundred
and ninety million and then I when I
read it when I read it I assumed it said
six hundred ninety million and then it's
at six nine zero thousand interesting
but like if they own two baseball teams
then shouldn't they be billionaires
yeah no by the way if you own a baseball
team like you are rich before because
you have to buy the baseball team like
nobody is start small with their
baseball team and then gets rich no
she's getting it's two of them right no
she's up there but I don't know the
baseball teams are worth something so
they their net worth would have to be at
least a billion dollars and you know if
she's a billionaire if she's a
billionaire like we'll give her a few
more episodes yeah but I just have to
say like for all the trouble we went to
to go to Dolce Gabbana's house that
atrocity of an outfit she ended up
walking out in was really a disgrace to
fashion
grace to women and a disgrace to life
well you know what like here's the thing
it really didn't suit her but I feel
like it would have been really cute on
me actually it would have been cute on
like Kyle Richards like I could see her
wearing
Doreen yeah Doreen Garcelle unwatched
repens live when she was asked which of
the ladies have the biggest ego she said
Kyle Richards I feel that I also feel
like it's warranted because she's the
last Oh G like Tracy Morgan you know and
look how she's acting first like Teresa
Giudice who's the last og to like Teresa
Giudice is a monster all right Kyle has
a bit of an ego will give it to her will
give it to her yeah I totally agree with
that okay I mean the most incredible
part was the last minute of like teasing
and showing and foreshadowing this huge
what's the word uh I can't show each
word Vegas oh yeah like this big thing
that we've been hearing about I wasn't
entirely sure the validity of it but
they they didn't pretend like it hadn't
gotten leads which I really appreciate
it like they acknowledge that people are
talking about how Brandi Glanville
exposed that allegedly her in Denise
Richards had an affair and that seems to
be the thing that kills the group for
Denise and they there it looks like they
come at it from a place of like we all
come on this show like no skeletons like
we have to be completely honest Lisa
Rinna's like I'm talking about my
daughter's eating disorder and I agree
with that but something about the way
like huija niece was before the show
makes me think like she didn't come on
this show to like a bear her all she
came on the show for a paycheck yeah um
I'm gonna I don't I feel like when we
see it all unravel we'll have different
thoughts because right now like yes I
agree you're supposed to put your life
out there but there's a lot that these
women don't show or don't talk about and
the other women respected so if Denise
is having an extramarital relationship
and either it is because she's in an
open marriage or not like that seems
like the type of thing that the other
women for each other would have
ordinarily protected you know and you
know even with Tori and her lawsuits or
like Kyle and Mauricio have been through
a lot
and Erica and her like there's old
there's a lot of stuff that comes up all
the time in the women like actually draw
a very hard line um that's why last
season when Camille came for two reads
finances it was like such a big deal and
so while they yes they are very
authentic and they share a lot of their
lives I wouldn't call them the cast
mates that bear all no I agree I agree
um I I do think that and I'm sure we'll
find out I don't think Denise Richards
was running around having an affair like
I'm she's been very open about her and
Aaron's like sexual you know rendezvous
rumps in the sack and I just think like
having somewhat of an open relationship
when it comes to like being with a woman
is a part of that and like who cares
well we'll see we'll see
I'm remaining open-minded about it
because I feel like watching it play out
we might feel a certain type of way that
we couldn't possibly feel right now
because we don't know anything yeah
but overall I just thought it was like
such a good episode such a good premiere
I love having these back every outfit
was just stellar stellar stellar like
Erika Jayne that'd be files like they
really have become because of the show
like so famous and I love that they're
leaning into that I love that the first
episode they went to New York I feel
like normally they maybe would have had
like one or two episodes like getting
ready for New York and like I just don't
need that like they just don't think
they have a lot of footage and like they
don't need a lot of filler episodes
which is very exciting and I'm just so
pleased with where the cast is out I
love how famous they are like I love how
Lisa Rinna like was famous before but is
now more famous than ever for being a
housewife Erika Jayne is so famous Kyle
is so famous like they're leaning into
like the Housewives Fame and it's not
like the the traditional Housewives fame
but has like a little bit of like a want
want to it it's like it's that's what
I'm forget where I read it but it's like
Beverly Hills is the crown jewel of the
Real Housewives franchise and it's so
true yeah it's so true it's it's such a
pleasure to have them back on TV I'm so
excited
I realize how much I missed all of them
and having like their fashion
inspiration in my life and also like
they make me realize how much the other
housewives and franchises like the
fashion is just like really bad some
would say a disgrace yeah someone say
that
okay so here's update on toast movie of
the day I didn't have time to finish
Hannah Montana in the movie because I
was up until 11:30 doing the redheads
and then I had to walk Beverly Hills so
then I started home on town movie but
then it was 2:00 a.m. and I had to go to
sleep so I'm gonna give one more day for
honey Montana in the movie because I'm
still gonna watch it because I was just
like loving it already
um and plus we have to watch her Honi
and Kardashians tonight yes so there'll
be a lot of stuff to recap on tomorrow's
show hopefully some more celebrity news
because today was a little little thin
like me mm-hmm know if that's it thank
you guys so much for listening to the
morning Tosa millennial Morning Show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe yeah yeah give
this video a thumbs up well available as
a podcast anywhere podcast when we found
so that Spotify iTunes stitcher public
radio I have radio cast box
oh the place is so ever you listen to
podcast find us the morning shows only
the five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are love you guys
very much hope you guys are staying safe
and when you'll see you back on zoom'
tomorrow bye